another week another Pokemon Sun and
Moon trailer this time we learned about
new Pokemon and game features I'm Tony
and this game spot news update will help
you catch them all first up is the
monkey Pokemon pass simian found only in
son version it has the new ability
receiver which lets it inherit the
ability of a fallen Ally moon versions
exclusive ape is a rang guru a normal
psychic type that wields a fan made of
leaves Wolf Pokemon Rock rough also
evolves differently in the game's Sun
version turns him into the midday form
of lichen rock while moon turns him into
the midnight form as her features
character customization is coming back
this time with new clothing and color
options and finally Pokemon bank will be
compatible with the new game but it
won't be available until January 2017
Pokemon Sun and Moon is coming to 3ds on
November eighteenth at this rate we'll
be seeing even more new Pokemon between
now and launch day so stay tuned to
gamespot for more and for all the
biggest pokemon news you're already in
the right place